Luffy isn't strong enough yet to become pirate
king.
As we now know, there is still a level above
what he's currently capable of.
That goes for his devil fruit, the voice of
all things, but most importantly for his haki
abilities.
There are still new and even more incredible
powers for Luffy to unlock and master before
he can claim the throne of the pirate world
and liberate the world.
The final power ups he will get before the
end of the story.
And Eiichiro Oda, the author of one piece,
has just revealed what these powers are.
Now, saying that Luffy still isn't powerful
enough might admittedly sound like a quite
bold statement after he just took out the
strongest creature in
the world.
Kaido was physically the strongest Emperor
among the original Yonko, with an incredible
devil fruit power and next level haki.
And Luffy managed to defeat him in a 1 vs
1 battle.
So what's the problem really?
Well as you well know, this fight says very
little about the enemies that are still to
come.
Kaido's title of the strongest creature conveniently
ignores two types of people: Those who he
has never fought before and those who have
just recently become stronger than him.
Luffy of course falling into that latter category.
Someone else who just recently has surpassed
Kaido at least as far as we know, is Luffy's
arch nemesis Marshal D. Teach.
I'm sure you agree that when LUffy will inevitably
face Blackbeard at some point, it will be
an even harder battle for our straw hats than
the beast pirates.
Blackbeard has not only 2 of the most powerful
devil fruits ever inn his possession, the
darkness fruit and the earthquake fruit, but
also has been building an army of the strongest
and most notorious pirates of this era, feeding
all of them powerful devil fruits.
Luffy right now would not be able to take
on Blackbeard.
Similarly, I think it's fair to argue that
someone like Akainu is also not going to be
an easy win for Luffy right now.
I've discussed this in more detail in my video
on the enemies that Luffy still has to face,
but Luffy getting a chance to fight Sakazuki
and revenge his brother's death is almost
guaranteed to happen at some point in the
story.
And he's sure to pose a real threat to anyone
who'd face him 1 vs 1.
And then of course there is the man, the myth,
the red haired legend himself.
Shanks has shown to us, that while he doesn't
wield a Devil fruit himself, haki wise is
on a completely different level from Kaido
as well.
And that brings us already to the first major
power-up that Luffy will get now that Wano
is over.
And for that I will also be getting into some
of the details revealed in the special one
piece volume 4Billion, that was distributed
for the release of film red.
It's not related to the movie itself really,
but the info revealed about Shanks is legitimately
canon.
And it's probably more than we have ever learned
about Shanks' true power in the regular story
itself.
Shanks' conquerors haki is the strongest in
the story.
We already pretty much knew that much, since
his legendary encounter with White Beard.
Not only did anyone outside the top brass
of Whitebeards man faint, remember, those
are men who have been sailing around the new
world and are well accustomed to its dangers,
but simply Shanks presence there damages the
Mobby Dick, whitebeards flagship physically.
The planks literally crack under the pressure
of his will.
And this is Shanks coming for a peaceful chat.
In other words, that's just his default mode.
Luffy himself finally learned about the true
potential of conquerers Haki during his fight
with Kaido.
He figured out to use it for fighting.
You can coat yourself and you attacks in conquerers
haki to deal devastating blows or defend yourself
against your opponents attack.
It's what made Kaido and Big Mom almost indestructible.
The users kingly will manifests physically,
which is why we see the sky split whenever
two yonko meet.
This explains why WHitebeard's ship took actual
damage.
However Shanks takes all of this to the nest
level.
His aura seems to be significantly larger
than that of luffy or Kaido, if it affects
people and objects of a 5 meter radius wherever
he goes.
And most terrifyingly, if you see him anywhere,
like right now, and you are not subscribed
to this channel he will drink all your booze.
But Shanks isn't just passively oozing his
conquerers haki, he has control over it like
no other character in the story, as he impressively
demonstrated during his driveway of Wano.
When Ryokugyuu was coming for Luffy's head
and facing off against momo and the scabbards,
Shanks was able to identify Aramaki's precise
location out of all people on wano at that
moment and direct an ultra-precise burst of
his haki towards him across many miles from
outside the country.
Shanks' conquerors haki attack was so powerful
that it paralysed and scared Aramaki, forcing
him to withdraw from Wano.
Let me repeat that: Shanks used his haki long
range to scare off a marine admiral, who had
just proven his terrifying strength.
That is a whole level above Luffy's and Kaido's
pay grade.
But it gets even crazier: Because we have
now learned about two other of Shanks abilities
from the special volume 4Billion, that's probably
named after his bounty.
Shanks has mastered an ability called KenbunGoroshi,
referring to observation haki, which in Japanese
is Kenbunshoku Haki.
Goroshi simply means killing.
In other words, Kenbungoroshi is literally
observation haki killing.
It's a technique that allows shanks to use
his conquerers haki to prevents his opponent
form using future sight.
This is of course a complete game changer.
Up to now it was always a question of who
has the stronger haki in a fight.
However suddenly we know that it's possible
to actually nullify another persons haki using
conquerers.
As you've probably also just thought about,
that means that someone like Katakuri who
has mastered his observation haki, would be
pretty much helpless against someone like
Shanks, completely robbed of his biggest strength.
Especially for someone who has integrated
such an ability into his fighting style, it
must come a complete shock to suddenly not
be able to rely on your most potent ability
anymore.
And let's not forget that Luffy also relies
quite a bit on future sight in his fights
as well at this point.
But that's not all, Oda-sensei has also revealed
that Shanks is able to coat his sword Gryphon
in a fiery aura when fighting against his
opponents.
And we do know for a fact that neither Shanks
nor any of his men have eaten a devil fruit.
So, Correct me if I'm wrong, but to me that
sounds like either one of two things: Either
shanks sword has eaten a devil fruit, which
would be pretty sick by itself, or, OR, Shanks
is able to generate flames with his Haki.
What does that remind you of?
Exactly, Luffy's mysterious fire powers he
uses with red hawk and red rock.
Shanks has opened up an entire new level of
power and fighting in one piece to us and
as you well know, Luffy won't be able to become
pirate king without reaching that same level
as well.
No matter if Shanks is actually chasing the
one piece himself or whether he will simply
test Luffy's power, I made a whole video on
that as well, reaching this level of mastery
over his conquerers haki will be a must for
Luffy now that he is moving towards the final
island.
But Haki isn't the only thing that our captain
still has room to grow in.
There are still other power-ups waiting for
us.
Like with Luffy's devil fruit.
Yes, Luffy has just awakened his fruit and
used his gear 5 for the first time, which
he himself called his pinnacle.
However, Luffy's devil fruit awakening was
active for a couple of minutes at the peak
of his fight with Kaido.
I think it's pretty fair to say, that Luffy
has not mastered the true potential of the
Nika devil fruit yet.
What we saw him do with it was incredibly
impressive, absolutely, but I think that there
must be more to its true power and potential
for the Gorosei to want to erase it form history.
The ability to shape its surroundings and
the fact that Luffy has been revealed to be
a zoan fruit open up so many possibilities.
What exactly IS gear 5 even?
Is it Nika awakened?
Is it simply Luffy's transformed form into
Nika?
What does his hybrid form look like?
As you can see, there are still so many unanswered
questions and things we don't know yet about
the Nika fruit.
And Luffy himself doesn'T even know yet, that
he is a Zoan user.
Once he finds out, he will be able to do so
much more with it, than right now.
I think we really only have seen the beginning
of what this devil fruit is truly capable
of and why it plays such an important role
in taking down the world government and changing
the world.
Then of course, there is the voice of all
things.
This power is still incredibly mysterious
and seems to be even rarer than having conqueror's
haki.
Luffy so far has used it only in a very limited
way.
He is able to detect peoples true feelings
and intentions and is able to communicate
with animals.
Which is a huge deal, don't get me wrong,
but there must be more to this mysterious
power, that might well be related to the D.
Clan itself, since Roger had it as well.
We do know for example, that Roger was able
to understand the poneglyphs to a certain
degree using this ability.
So what else is it capable of?
It might actually be the key to finding and
using the one piece.
The secret ability of the D clan.
And let's not forget the ancient weapons.
We know that Poseidon, Pluton and Uranus are
all connected to Joy Boy and the void century.
All three are powerful enough to destroy the
world.
Terrible Weapons that can be used for either
good or bad.
But in the end, it sounds like Luffy will
be needing them in order to fulfil his dream
and create a new world where everyone is free
to live a happy life.
These 3 weapons are truly mysterious.
However, we might already know what their
secret is and how they work.
These weapons might be more complex and sophisticated
than we all could have dreamed.
They seem to include genetic engineering,
gigantuous monsters and colossal vessels.
And if you really want to learn how they might
work, you really shouldn't skip this video
right here.